oui hara kiri à 20 ans d'existence une
existence qui n'a pas toujours été
facile
tiens à le dire quelques interdictions
et surtout pas mal de procès faut dire
qu'il lui a pas beaucoup je crois de
sujets tabous dans hara-kiri alors
gérard holtz a voulu en savoir plus il a
voulu surtout en savoir plus sur les
pages bricolage de ce magazine et oui ça
existe aussi des pages réalisé par le
célèbre professeur show prend les une
boîte de sardines poser dessus une
feuille de papier à cigarette
prenez une pincée de tabac placez la sur
la faille
assis gheit empoigné le problème
glissez le dans la langue est est vous
ouvrez la boîte tournée fait un peu
difficile mais ça marche on y est
ça y est arraché le compétent et
maintenant en tirons le couvercle sûrs
ou les engrais la clé on sait là prenez
votre couvert pu rouler renverser le
regarder la cigarette et rouler en plus
vous avez un magnifique fume cigarette
aux religieuses
comment ça se passe à hara kiri pour
trouver les idées c'est bien c'est une
travail des équipes l'équipe c'est vous
les connaissez ce cas but reiser
kavanagh gb rollins qui scella la grande
équipe de départ etc on trouve les idées
tous ensemble autour d'une table et
chaque fois il sort ce journal qui
s'appelle hara kiri inquiets vis ça a
été une invention mondial parce qu'il
n'y avait pratiquement pas ailleurs même
dans les pays étrangers de journal
équivalent oui je crois que ces mêmes
heures enfin je crois qu'en france c'est
même le seul pays ou hara kiri peut
paraître peut être édité
même avec tous les ennuis qu'on l'a eue
sur les interdictions et tout dans ce
cas m sortie la france est le seul pays
où on pourrait produire hara-kiri moi je
crois que là le grand succès d'harry
crise c'est que premièrement c'est c'est
pratiquement le seul journal d'humour
qui existant dans le monde partout
d'ailleurs l'humour et sophistiquée us
et c'est de l'humour où on souriez sur
laval sur la pointe des lèvres comme si
on peut dire tandis qu'elle est ce qu on
a cherché à faire aquiris c'est le rire
à gorge déployée quand c'est ce qu'on
cherche faire rire à gorge déployée cède
à plaisanterie de salles de garde c'est
de la plaisanterie création c'est de la
plaisanterie de potache
c'est tout ce qu'on a essayé de faire
avec car akyol
[Musique]